let's now see if we could come up with
the chemical formula for the ionic
compound calcium bromide and like always
if you are inspired pause the video and
see if you could come up with it on your
own
alright so the convention is is that we
write the positive ion first and so
there's a pretty good clue that calcium
is going to be the positive ion now
let's look at the periodic table to
confirm that it's likely that calcium
would ionize as a cation well calcium is
right over here in
group two
and group two elements also known as
alkaline earth metals they tend to
ionize by losing two electrons and
that's because they have two electrons
in their outermost shell and they would
like to lose them and so when calcium
ionizes it is going to be
it is going to ionize as
ca
2 plus
now let's look at the bromide part
the ide tells us that this is going to
be a negative
ion or it's going to be an anion and if
you look at where bromine sits in our
periodic table right over here we see it
is a halide we see that it likes to gain
an electron and so it makes sense that
it's going to be our anion and so
bromine is going to would like to gain
an electron to have eight electrons in
its outermost shell
so our bromide anion is going to look
like this it's going to be one minus
it's going to want to gain an electron
that's what these the elements in this
group like to do
now what is the formula going to be and
remember the key here is for an ionic
compound especially one that has well
we don't see any net charge here for an
ionic compound we're going to have no
these things are going to cancel each
other out the charge of the calcium
anion the calcium cation is going to
cancel out with the bromine
with the bromide anions so how is that
going to happen
well you have two plus here you only
have one minus here so you're going to
have to have two bromides for every of
the calcium ions so this is going to be
you're going for every one of the
calciums you're going to have two
bromides
so it's going to be like this br2
and there you have it that is the
chemical formula for calcium bromide
and how did we know that we have two
bromides for every calcium well because
when calcium ionizes it's going to be
two plus it's a group two element right
over here and bromine only gets a
negative one or one minus charge so
you're going to need two of the bromides
for every one of the calciums